we're told that the formula for
converting a Celsius temperature into
Fahrenheit is the Celsius temperature or
C is equal to 5/9 times the Fahrenheit
temperature - 32 rewrite the formula so
it solves for Fahrenheit so just like I
mentioned the C is a Celsius is the
Celsius temperature and the F is the
Fahrenheit temperature Fahrenheit
temperature so right now it's expressed
in terms of we've solved for C in terms
of F now we want to solve for F in terms
of C so let's see how we're gonna do
that so I'll just rewrite it C is equal
to 5/9 times F - 32 and we want to solve
for F so the first useful thing to do
might be to get rid of this five nights
from both sides or at least from the
right side of the equation so we just
have an F - 32 and the easiest way to do
that is to multiply by the inverse of
five ninths so if we multiply both sides
of this equation by 9/5 and I could put
it here but it'll squeeze a little
tighter let me try nine fifths in there
if I do to the right-hand side of the
equation I also have to do it to the
left-hand side of the equation and what
do I get the left-hand side becomes nine
fifths Celsius or the Celsius
temperature nine fifths times the
Celsius temperature is equal to the
whole reason we wanted to multiply the
right side by nine fifths is these 9s
cancel out this five cancel out and this
just becomes a one so nine fifths times
the Celsius temperature is going to be
equal to this expression the Fahrenheit
temperature - 32 we don't need the
parentheses anymore because this is the
only expression on the right-hand side
now we want to we want to solve for the
Fahrenheit temperature so let's see if
we can get rid of this 32 from the
right-hand side easiest way I know how
to do that is to add 32 add 32 to both
sides of this equation
add 32 to both sides the left-hand side
now becomes 9 fifths times the Celsius
temperature plus 32 nine fifths times
the Celsius temperature
Plus 32 and that's going to be equal to
this negative 32 and positive 32 cancel
out that was the whole point behind
adding 32 so it's just going to be equal
to F and we're done
we have rewritten this formula up here
so it solves for Fahrenheit this is the
Fahrenheit right here we've solved for
Fahrenheit in terms of the Celsius
temperature